es igual
[Música]
una llamada de teléfono del presidente
turco eso es todo lo que ha necesitado
donald trump para tomar una decisión que
supone ni más ni menos que traicionar
otra vez a uno de sus mayores aliados en
oriente medio' el pueblo kurdo la
minoría étnica más grande de la región
sin estado propio hablamos de entre 25 y
35 millones de personas pero no penséis
que esta es la primera tradición de eeuu
contra sus aliados kurdos ni mucho menos
dadas las circunstancias es algo que
resulta sorprendente pero lo cierto es
que la mayor potencia occidental
colecciona decisiones difíciles de
entender si tenemos en cuenta que el
pueblo kurdo ha luchado en prácticamente
todos los conflictos de la zona del lado
de los intereses de eeuu
los kurdos han estado junto a los
norteamericanos en los peores momentos y
no pocas ocasiones cuando los
estadounidenses han querido ahorrarse
víctimas propias han servido como mano
de batalla
precisamente por este motivo los cursos
han sido armados y equipados durante
décadas por los eeuu ahora bien ni por
un solo segundo penséis que hablamos
sólo de cuestiones del pasado para nada
la última ocasión en la que las tropas
kurdas han sido decisivas fue
prácticamente antes de ayer durante la
lucha contra el estado islámico que
entre los años 2015 y 2016 invadió buena
parte del territorio iraquí de hecho no
es descabellado decir que sin los kurdos
es muy posible que el isi seguiría
siendo una estructura fuerte hoy en día
probablemente no estaríamos hablando en
absoluto de un falso califato reducido a
escombros sino seguramente de un
problema de escala mucho pero que mucho
mayor por todo esto en este vídeo vamos
a responder a dos preguntas clave porque
los kurdos son tan importantes para eeuu
y también para turquía y cómo y por qué
los eeuu les han traicionado
reiteradamente a lo largo de la historia
estáis preparados pues atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos de visual política a
estas alturas del juego hay algo muy
claro claro meridiano la política
internacional del presidente trampe es
cómo decirlo diferente por calificarla
de alguna forma es curiosa tal vez
chocante inestable volátil caprichosa
bueno mejor paramos digamos que es
difícil de describir
escucha
y
[Música]
el caso es que su forma condescendiente
de actuar y cómo decirlo su gusto en
alabar a tiranos como kim jong-un ya
presidentes poco o nada democráticos
como putin gordo gan ha generado la
comunidad internacional una cierta
perplejidad y no es de extrañar pensarlo
un momento y en día andrés va a fiar de
un país dirigido por un presidente que
una y otra y otra vez se alinea con
semejantes tipos mientras castiga a sus
aliados la administración trump anuncia
aranceles al whisky el queso y aviones
de la unión europea
trump pone la política por delante del
sentido común con la guerra comercial
con la unión europea amistoso lo que se
dice amistoso pues no resulta nos parece
[Música]
pues bien ahora esta forma de hacer
política tan inestable le ha tocado a
los kurdos trump ha seguido un
planteamiento que podríamos definir como
donde dije digo digo diego y como lo ha
hecho pues veréis básicamente apartando
las tropas norteamericanas para dejar
vía libre para que las tropas kurdas
ataquen a sus aliados kurdos en el norte
de siria si si tal como lo estáis
escuchando la retirada de las tropas de
eeuu del norte de siria ha comenzado
dice
y esto llega después de que turquía
planearse una operación en el este del
río éufrates en el norte de siria el
vergonzoso abandono de trump a los
kurdos los eeuu le deben a las fuerzas
democráticas sirias cierta lealtad por
su lucha contra el estado islámico no me
digáis que esto no os parece algo grave
[Música]
por lo menos por lo menos no me negaréis
que la mejor forma para tratar un aliado
pues no parece no creéis ahora bien un
momento vale es verdad el problema es
bastante más complejo de lo que parece
porque en toda esta historia eeuu se
encuentra en mitad de dos grandes
adversarios los turcos y los kurdos
así que llegados a este punto hay una
cuestión que tenemos que resolver antes
de nada qué diablos sucede entre turquía
y los kurdos porque eeuu parece tener
una posición tan rocambolesca en todo
este asunto atentos
[Música]
turquía o los kurdos
para eeuu para prácticamente toda la
comunidad internacional y para cualquier
persona interesada en lo que ocurre en
el mundo las relaciones entre turquía y
los kurdos son siempre siempre un dolor
de cabeza fijaos
por un lado turquía es un aliado
fundamental importantísimo tanto para
estados unidos como para los países
europeos turquía es miembro de la otan y
tiene una posición geográfica
privilegiada hablamos de un país situado
en el extremo este de europa cerca de
rusia y en la misma puerta de oriente
medio un país que tiene fronteras ni más
ni menos que con irán irak y siria
vamos en otras palabras que la posición
de turquía es tan importante que para
preservar sus intereses allí las
potencias occidentales están dispuestas
a ser permisivas con las acciones del
gobierno turco y eso el presidente turco
erdogán lo sabe eso es lo que explica
por ejemplo su acercamiento a rusia o
sus constantes conflictos con la unión
europea
por otro lado tenemos a los kurdos que
son uno de los pueblos más moderados de
oriente medio a pesar de ser una
sociedad mayoritariamente musulmana
tienen un marcado carácter secular y una
fuerte oposición al islamismo radical de
esta forma durante décadas los kurdos
han luchado con provisiones y armas de
eeuu en multitud de conflictos y guerras
contra dictaduras locales y grupos
islamistas como el estado islámico hasta
hacerlos prácticamente desaparecer
ya lo veis tanto turquía como el pueblo
kurdo han sido durante las últimas
décadas aliados clave de las grandes
potencias occidentales el problema es
que las relaciones entre los turcos y
los kurdos no podrían ser peores porque
pues fijaos porque es un conflicto que
viene de lejos
[Música]
tras el final de la primera guerra
mundial el tratado de ser firmado en
parís en 1920 entre turquía y los países
aliados excepto rusia y eeuu reconocía
la desmembración del imperio otomano y
la creación por ejemplo de un estado
kurdo así que lógicamente los kurdos
esperaban poder tener su propio estado
sin embargo este tratado nunca llegó a
implantarse los nacionalistas turcos
liderados por atatürk se sublevaron
tomaron el poder y forzaron consiguieron
que eeuu acordará un nuevo tratado en
1923 el de luján que borraba del mapa
ese posible estado kurdo
amigos desde entonces los cursos han
estado organizados política y
militarmente con un objetivo enfrentarse
a turquía y lograr el estado que el
tratado de sèvres les prometió por
supuesto esto es algo que ha ido de mal
en peor dando lugar a uno de los
conflictos más enquistados del planeta
el brazo militar del partido de los
trabajadores del kurdistán termino ni
más ni menos que perpetrando durante
décadas sangrientos atentados en turquía
al tiempo que el ejército turco por su
parte no tuvo reparos en llevar a cabo
duras represalias claro que no sólo hay
kurdos en turquía también los hay en
irán irak y siria
[Música]
y precisamente las organizaciones kurdas
de irak y siria han sido estrechos
aliados de eeuu durante los últimos años
pero amigos lo cierto es que para el
gobierno turco de una forma u otra todo
viene a formar parte de lo mismo en
cierto modo entienden que si en alguno
de estos lugares se conformarán
gobiernos kurdos autónomos
independientes pues es que eso supondría
una grave amenaza sobre su soberanía así
que ya veis la cosa está complicada no
os parece
y esto nos lleva a una pregunta clave si
de ti dependerá si de ti a quién
apoyarían a los turcos o a los kurdos
pues amigos esa es la pregunta que
durante mucho tiempo se han hecho en
washington y sabéis que visto lo visto
parece que a la hora de la verdad es el
poderoso el que se lleva el gato al agua
[Música]
claro vamos a ver sobre la mesa quién es
el más prescindible a quién va a
preferir washington a un estado
históricamente consolidado y fuerte
económica y militarmente oa un pueblo
sin estado si ésta fuese una pregunta de
examen a aprobar lo que se dice aprobar
no parecería algo complicado no creéis
pues este es precisamente el motivo por
el que los kurdos se han visto
traicionados o al menos dejado de lado
por eeuu en multitud de ocasiones desde
comienzos del siglo 20 y la última ha
sido hace muy poco a principios de este
mismo mes de octubre 2019 y ha tenido un
claro protagonista
donald trump atentos
ok
la última traición de trump
amigos que eeuu le haya dado la espalda
a sus aliados kurdos no es algo que haya
pasado ni una ni dos ni tres veces sino
al menos siete u ocho veces eso que se
sepa sin ir más lejos una de las
tradiciones más graves y que más
polémica ha causado en la clase política
y militar de eeuu es la que ha impulsado
el presidente donald trump a principios
de octubre de 2019
trump anunció y ejecutó la retirada de
efectivos estadounidenses en la frontera
noreste de siria después de una llamada
con erdogán los efectivos entre 100 y
150 se han movilizado hacia otras zonas
de siria pero el movimiento supone a
abrir el paso al ejército turco para
permitirles entrar en enfrentamiento
directo contra los kurdos de las fuerzas
democráticas sirias que han sido clave
en la derrota del issys
uy
fighting y específicamente ya lo veis
así es como tras agradecer los
sacrificios de quienes han colaborado en
terminar con este reino del terror que
ha sido lisis como os quedáis porque con
amigos así casi que mejora hasta luego y
buenas tardes así que en fin visto lo
visto no podemos extrañarnos de que los
kurdos se sientan traicionados y
engañados los kurdos sirios ven una
traición estadounidense y advierten de
que la lucha contra el issys ahora está
en duda pero un momento no penséis que
esto es lo más grave para nada
lo peor es que esta decisión siembra un
precedente muy peligroso porque se carga
de un plumazo la confianza de los
aliados de oriente medio en eeuu por
otro oriente medio y de prácticamente
cualquier otro lugar del planeta al fin
y al cabo si hoy traicionan a los kurdos
que les podrían pasar a otro es mañana
qué incentivo tienen los grupos afines a
los intereses de occidente en confiar en
eeuu para colaborar con ellos digamos
que resultaría complicado pues un
momento porque aún no os hemos contado
cómo se ha tomado esta decisión trampean
a un consejo agarrados a la silla
en circunstancias normales podríamos
esperar que un presidente tome una
decisión tan importante teniendo cierto
consenso o acuerdo con la cúpula del
pentágono con las recomendaciones del
departamento de estado o incluso con los
líderes políticos de su propio partido
en el congreso y en el senado pues bien
ninguna de estas tres cosas ha pasado
porque si trump es diferente y la
decisión la ha tomado con todos
absolutamente con todos los actores
relevantes en su contra
vamos que lo ha hecho por sus narices
que sabrán eso presionado del pentágono
el departamento de estado en washington
our life fighting jaime coll armani wind
and fire el caso es que esto es algo que
no ha sentado nada pero que nada bien en
las filas del partido republicano sobre
todo si tenemos en cuenta que trump ya
intentó una retirada de siria en
diciembre de 2018 algo que terminó con
la dimisión del secretario de defensa a
james mattis y también del entonces
enviado especial presidencial para la
coalición contra liesbeth mack work
y
[Aplausos]
y es
quizás por eso en esta ocasión
personalidades de primer nivel ojo de su
propio partido como es el caso del líder
de la mayoría republicana en el senado
mitch mcconnell han hecho un comunicado
en contra de esta decisión los
republicanos del senado rechazan la
decisión de trump de abandonar a los
kurdos
urjo al presidente a ejercer el
liderazgo estadounidense para mantener
unida nuestra coalición multinacional
para derrotar al estado islámico y
evitar un conflicto importante entre
nuestro aliado de la otan turquía y
nuestros socios locales en siria en la
lucha contra el terrorismo
mitch mcconnell líder de la mayoría
republicana en el senado y no sólo eso
otros senadores de renombre como lindsey
graham también del partido republicano
alertan de los riesgos que traen no está
queriendo ver e incluso han propuesto
sanciones contra turquía y la misma
exclusión de la otan y finalmente este
país realiza una invasión del norte de
siria pasando por encima de los kurdos
introduciremos sanciones bipartidistas
contra turquía si invaden siria y
pediremos su suspensión de la otan si
atacan a las fuerzas kurdas que
asistieron a eeuu en la destrucción del
califato del issys senador republicano
lindsey graham en twitter de la misma
forma también algunos líderes políticos
internacionales próximos a eeuu como es
el caso de benjamin netanyahu ya han
pronunciado en la misma dirección
israel condena enérgicamente la invasión
turca de las áreas kurdas en siria y
advierte contra la limpieza étnica de
los kurdos por parte de turquía y sus
representantes israel está preparado
para extender la asistencia humanitaria
al galante pueblo kurdo
benjamin netanyahu
[Música]
y sabéis que ya no se trata sólo de una
cuestión de lealtad hacia los aliados lo
que es importante sino incluso también
de seguridad por ejemplo sin ir más
lejos las tropas kurdas mantienen
retenidos a más de 30.000 militantes
leales al estado islámico militantes que
por supuesto podrían quedar en libertad
en caso de conflicto con turquía curioso
eso de golpear a tu amigo que te está
haciendo el trabajo sucio en fin cosas
de trampa pero amigos conociendo al
actual inquilino de la casa blanca
seguramente muchos preguntaréis cómo
diantres ha reaccionado y presidente
como día en tres ha reaccionado donald
trump pues con su estilo bandazos
amenazas y bueno vosotros mismos como ya
he dicho claro anteriormente y sólo para
reiterar los y turquía hace algo que en
mi grandiosa e inigualable sabiduría
consideró fuera de los límites destruir
y arrasar e totalmente la economía de
turquía ya lo he hecho antes
donald trump presidente de los eeuu en
twitter grandiosa e inigualable
sabiduría en fin sin comentarios primero
toma una decisión turquía no festeja lo
un bandazo y luego una bravuconada bueno
el estilo trump por cierto no es la
primera vez que este presidente
traiciona los kurdos ya lo hizo en irak
y en 2017 os contamos en este vídeo que
estaba pasando desde entonces lo que ha
ocurrido es ni más ni menos que eeuu el
gobierno de trump miró pues para otro
lado pero ahora llegados a este punto
turno para ti cuál crees que debe ser la
posición de eeuu en este conflicto
debería a eeuu aproximarse más a los
kurdos al haber sido buenos aliados
durante los últimos años o debería
seguir apoyando a turquía esta trump
cometiendo acaso su enésima
irresponsabilidad como presidente dejado
sus comentarios y opiniones aquí abajo
por cierto un aviso ya sabéis todos que
tenemos un canal en inglés junto a simon
whistler sin duda uno de los youtubers
uno de los creadores más prolíficos de
toda esta red pues bien el caso es que
ahora simon ha lanzado un nuevo canal
sobre biografías en castellano así que
os invitamos a pasaros y suscribiros
porque la verdad merece la pena en fin
si os ha gustado este vídeo no olvidéis
darle a like y una vez más de corazón
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima